vous êtes l'idole de tout votre
génération la beauté 1958
questionne m
j'ai été voir un producteur pour un rôle
de vente si tu m'avais lui l'amande
caméléon je te jure à la façade bien
marrant un jour france rapetissée le
lendemain pour marcher sur la pointe des
pieds car j'ai déjà fait le rôle d'une
ross d'une gourde d'une fille mère même
d'une intellectuelle mais cinq ans ne
m'était jamais arrivé brigitte bardot
des millions et des millions de
téléspectateurs en 7 secondes vous voir
paraître au centre de leurs écrans vous
avez quelque chose à leur dire de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit des abattoirs c'est à dire de
la façon dont on tue les animaux encore
à notre époque
les animaux sont égorgés
c'est à dire que les petits animaux les
volets moutons et les chèvres sont
égorgés vivants
pensez pas que le public va trouve
étrange que vous occupiez de cela qu'il
va se dire je m étais pourquoi pas fons
les déjà dit après pour l'autre chose
oui vous savez je pense que je suis
peut-être une des rares personnes au
monde qui n'est pas simple